this mission has been anything but
straightforward we have to adapt we have
to be agile to make sure that we don't
put a three billion dollar asset in
harm's way
these flybys are planned out many many
months and sometimes years in advance
and so something is discovered and we
can do something about it we'll stop at
nothing well we're literally day and
night in order to make these new
observations that the scientists you
know desperately want to make that
Russia is building to rethink the route
map immediately the scientists wanted to
get much much closer to get
high-resolution imaging but also move
the closest approach from the northern
hemisphere to the southern hemisphere we
finally arrived at a solution and we
lowered the altitude from a thousand
climbers all the way down to 165
kilometers this pass is seven times
closer than the first flyby the
discoveries are worth the diversion this
was the flyby where we saw for the very
first time these fissures in the south
polar region that was later named the
tiger stripes the stripes are gaping
wounds where pressure from below opens
vents to the surface they're marked by
whiter fresh ice solidifying along the
cracks we saw about a dozen or more Jets
erupting 200 or more kilometers above
the surface of the South Pole we
strongly suspected that these were
geysers that if this was vapour and
particles coming from these fractures
nothing now is more important than
Enceladus wanted to go back again and
again to learn more and even fly through
and taste what was coming out of those
jets the scientists thirst for knowledge
can butt up against the need for
spacecraft safety and the guardian of
that is Julie Webster the engineering
team is the 900-pound gorilla if we
don't think it's safe we win but you're
there to take science so if you don't
take the data because you're too scared
you're not gonna get what you're there
for we had to learn a lot about this
plume what was it made of how dense was
it was a variable and time variable in
geometry to answer such questions
Cassini Dicey's with real danger we're
talking about an object that over a
billion kilometres from Earth we went
all the way down to 25 kilometers from
the surface a very very hard surface
going you know in excess of eight or ten
kilometers per seconds we're moving the
terrifying manoeuvre reveals how active
this moon is we found over a hundred and
one geysers and material coming from the
fractures and other teams found that the
vapour contains simple organic compounds
those geysers are coming from an ocean
that is salty comparable to the salinity
of the Earth's ocean and it's shooting
into space
[Music]